you can't play a child murdering clown
and expect to walk away unscathed when
you get into the mindset of an evil
ancient entity you might wind up in some
pretty dark places like Bill skarsgård
hats here's why the swedish star has
never quite been the same since it penny
wise is without a doubt scarce cards
most famous role to date and for a good
reason
the actors portrayal of a killer clown
has received near universal praise among
critics and film goers one of the key
reasons for all of the praise is the
physicality of the role regarding his
part the actor told the New York Times
everything I did took 100% of my energy
it was by far the most exhausting
character I've ever done physically and
mentally in the blu-ray special feature
penny wise lives
skarsgård spoke about the physical
considerations of playing penny wise
saying he often passed on using stunt
doubles anyways his physicality must be
penny wise physicality and I wanted to
bring my movement and physicality and as
much as I could
except for physically dangerous scenes
skarsgård insisted on always playing
penny wise himself a decision that
frequently left him utterly exhausted on
set how does one begin to portray an
inhuman shapeshifter that literally
feeds off of the fear of other beings
one way that skarsgård went about this
was to think about how penny wise
interacted with the other characters in
the film
skarsgård told Entertainment Weekly I
like in every character that I do - a
relationship that you're in penny wise
and Bill going to this sort of
relationship together and I'm trying to
figure out who he is and I have to
devote so much time and effort to this
other person or thing in this case and
that goes on for months in an interview
with Collider skarsgård further
elaborated on his approach to playing
penny wise telling them about how he
tried to get into penny wise his head to
better understand the creature saying it
really enjoyed being the clown he
preferred to take the shape of the clown
obviously that opened ways of thinking
why does he prefer being the clown but
also there is this sense of enjoyment
the entity that is it is enjoying being
the clown there were a lot of abstract
ways to look at it I tried to take all
of those into consideration when I
embodied the character while skarsgård
managed to scare audiences around the
world his fellow actors also found
themselves frequently unsettled by penny
wise while working on the film because
the majority of it surrounds penny wise
with the members of the so-called losers
Club many of the scenes require
skarsgård
work directly with child actors to keep
the children's reactions as realistic as
possible
skarsgård tried to stay in character
whenever he was working he explained to
interview magazine on sets I wasn't very
friendly or goofy I tried to maintain
some sort of weirdness about the
character at least when I was in all the
makeup additionally when he was in
costume skarsgård was kept completely
separate from the other actors playing
his young victims between takes because
of this the children had no idea what
Pennywise would look like in each scene
bill recalled when he realized just how
effective the separation tactic was he
told interview this one kid started
crying he started to cry in the director
yelled action and when they say action I
am completely in character so some of
these kids got terrified and started to
cry in the middle of the tape and then I
realized holy SH what am i doing
what is this this is horrible when
preparing to play in it bill skarsgård
saw his connection to penny wise as a
toxic relationship follow one that had
some good moments as he explained to
Entertainment Weekly it's just like
being in a very destructive relationship
all of your friends go you need to dump
this piece of he or she is destroying
your life and then once you're out of it
you see I was so miserable but I
wouldn't say I was miserable doing penny
wise because I had a lot of fun with it
as well considering the emotional toll
of playing penny wise it's no surprise
that skarsgård felt relief after filming
for it concluded every scene I'm in in
this film was just a hundred percent
energy at all times it's all DW that
after finishing up the first movie he
went back to his childhood home in
Sweden and one day he was visiting with
his mom and joined the coffee and the
company when he suddenly realized that
he was free from Pennywise he explained
it was a very quick shift of just
feeling better like oh my god I'm
relieved that I don't have to deal with
the darkness of the character I likened
it to an exorcism him exiting my body
and getting rid of the Pennywise toxins
scars guards Pennywise didn't just scare
moviegoers skarsgård himself was haunted
by the killer clown even after filming
concluded he told Entertainment Weekly I
was home done with the movie and I
started having very strange and vivid
Pennywise dreams every night he came in
visited skarsgård further elaborated on
the dreams saying that they generally
took one of two forms and one he was
having to deal with penny wise as a
separate entity and the other type he
found himself as penny wise in weird
situations
out in public with people staring at it
though the thought of Pennywise haunting
someone's dreams is without a doubt a
terrifying premise the actor sees his
nightly visits from Pennywise in a more
optimistic light skarsgård believes
these dreams are his psyche attempting
to quote let the character go despite
these dark dreams
skarsgård thinks he's in a good place as
he explained the e:w it was amazing it's
a daunting but exciting thing to sort of
revisit him again I'm good with it
despite the trouble Bill skarsgård went
through after playing Pennywise the
first time around it was inevitable that
he'd have to step back into his clown
shoes for the sequel after spending so
much time and devoting so much emotional
energy to being free of Pennywise
skarsgård told collider in an interview
that he didn't have any trouble getting
back in touch with the dancing clown as
he explained I was surprised how much of
the character was just there already
I could instantly access him again like
it was yesterday that we wrapped the
first one it was just all there so the
work and preparation and figuring out
the character is almost intuitive which
is pretty cool check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite horror
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]